here's what New York Times had five
takeaways from this book the scientists
avoids clashing with Donald Trump the
Santa's Praises Trump for bringing a
unique star power to the 2016 campaign
he criticizes the Russia investigation
and mostly blames Dr Anthony fauci and
other health experts for federal
government's initial response to the
coronavirus pandemic uh yeah because
Russia was fake and fauci and them were
wrong okay for the way they handled it
and Florida showed that they did it the
right way not some other states now
again that is my opinion a lot of
numbers can show that but that's the
first part second descent is underplays
Trump's influence it's widely accepted
that Trump's support was critical to
census victory in 2018 race for governor
but the sentence presents a different
take his debate performance was the
Clincher he writes I disagree I read the
book The Scientist specifically said
that President Trump one time before
DeSantis even announced he's running he
asked them for a favor to say something
Trump tweeted about the scientists
saying if he ever ran he would be great
prior to him announcing then DeSantis
announced that he's running for governor
and then when it's getting close when
the debate happened between him and um
Andrew Gillum uh yeah not Gillum the one
the Republican uh Charlie Chris not
Charlie Chris no no the Santa is the
first one he went with not yeah 2018.
Andrew Gillum is it gives me 18. okay so
he's going against Gilman they're having
the debate and then it comes to the
point where he needs an endorsement then
Trump tweeted again so he gave credit to
Trump supporting him twice in the book
so whatever New York Times is saying if
a person if the average person doesn't
read the book they're going to say oh
did you see what he did in the book he
clearly states if it wasn't for those
tweets that would have not been the same
so he gave credit I just want to make
sure people know that number three the
Santa sees the covet Pivot Point when
2020 got uh underway I was merely a
state Governor entering his second year
in office to census rights within six
months I would emerge as one of the
leading anti-lockdown elected officials
in the world yeah that's a pretty big
decision number four DeSantis boast of
his use of executive power both critics
and courts have rebuked the governor for
executive overreach but the sentences
unbowed he writes proudly about
promising to overly overrule any major
that did not want to host Ultimate
Fighting Championship events during the
pandemic the book touts his removal of
the elected prosecutor in Tampa a
Democrat and he called state budget
vetoes a source of a leverage against
GOP lawmakers who do not want to face
primaries he explains all of that in the
book this is the way there you're going
to say something no say don't forget
about Point number one it's not just the
UFC where did the NBA that's right where
did the Super Bowl
where did AOC go for vacation for
Christmas right
does not dish anyone looking for inside
insight into the famously close off
Governor will be disappointed the census
offers a few behind the scenes details
and skips over some parts of his
biography entirely including the 2016
run for U.S Senate he does write about
Mary and his wife Casey at Disney world
but without Mickey Mouse or Donald Duck
in our wedding photos you know I will
tell you this from reading it
you know how the book was written I've
worked with people like DeSantis in my
career and people like the scientists in
my career that I've met they're very uh
they're very uh they're both structured
like let me tell you this is the kind of
guy that from 25 years ago he was
careful on every text and email that he
wrote because he knows this day was
coming not you okay this is the guy
that's very methodical who gets in who's
close I can probably tell you he
probably doesn't have 40 friends
that's the kind of guy that probably has
two to five friends Max is what the
Santa's got and that's intentional this
is not a guy that trusts a lot of
different people this is not a guy that
lets a lot of people into his life so if
a person says things like that would I
say yeah they're right yeah if you read
the book there's some parts of it where
he's aloof he's not giving you a lot but
that's because that's his personality
I mean that's think about having no
vision that Focus that dedication path
from all those years to know that all
those years later it's going to come to
a point where you're not going to have
that grab them by the you know what
moment or the this or the text or the
you're just a clean cut you hope oh
don't get me wrong if he is the front
guy the left is 100 gonna find some
because they have people looking at that
right now for Trump number two if you
know if you know he's running and For
The Senses but it's going to be way more
difficult to find it on this guy bro I
found way more difficult I found that
reviewed by the times a little more
balanced than I would have expected from
the times but there is one thing that
they they they need to go look in the
mirror catch a little reflection oh he
abuses executive power it's the New York
Times that's been asking Biden to use
the executive order pen against
conservatives for the past two years and
they were pushing Obama last day in
office to do you know certain executive
orders so let's let's calm down on that
part of it because that's the way this
game is played exactly
yeah obviously he's um he's kind of what
he did with talking about these five
points right here he's basically saying
thanks Trump but no thanks exactly like
appreciate it uh what he does here with
Point number two like he's saying he
thinks you got me in 2018. but thanks
I'm kind of this way now but no no
disrespect he's kind of not talking
trash out there even though Trump
you talk about what's going on he leaked
that picture of Ron the sanctimonious
with underage girls like Trump's gotta
have some more stuff up his Playbook I
think at the end of the day if you're
asking just any old average American
um what they think that uh the Santa
sort of represents freedom and Trump is
more the chaos candidate and uh that's
not who's going to be uh in the primary
I mean uh but for a general election you
know what I saw today I think it was on
Vanity Fair or I saw it on uh Economist
or one of them where it said Trump can
still be president even if he's uh
convicted or he's charged or he's this
that's kind of what they were saying
really yeah so so there is listen there
is a lot of fear is this the one yeah
here it is this is from who can you tell
me who this is from ABC ABC Trump could
still be elected president if indicted
or convicted experts say okay so let me
ask you why would ABC write this article
why why would you be hit on on who on
Trump they want to keep the heat on
Trump they want to keep people revved up
attacking Trump they don't want people
they do not want people to back off they
that's that's the last thing they want
oh he's been indicted he can't go so you
back off and what that does that clears
the runway for DeSantis not to have to
build momentum and not have to deal with
the Trump conflict
yeah I think to me am I making ABC stuff
too smart no I get it I I think I think
it shows signs of weakness and fear that
Trump could win
I think this so shows signs of fear that
Trump could win so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign